hello freak [ __ ] talk about this in
much detail because it's really
complicated but the the anti left
spectrum let's say is very confused and
it could easily tilt very rapidly into
the hard right anti left which is the
danger that that you are describing and
partly what I'm hoping is that I can
talk to people who might conceivably be
on that developmental pathway because
they're they're tired of being accused
of implicit racism let's say and say
look you can be anti radical left
without falling all the way into the to
the far right and here's how you might
do it but that means I have to talk to
them and then if I talk to them that
means I risk association with them and
that risks being tainted it's a very
tricky line to walk well it's also one
of the one of the big problems with this
hard stance of the of the left of the
hard left like this Pepe the Frog thing
like that anybody I mean one of the
things that I tweeted was some guy that
called me you just admitted you're a
Nazi because you I posted a meme that
someone had created of me as Pepe the
Frog that apparently there's Pepe the
Frog of everybody and so I thought this
guy was like well you just admitted
you're a Nazi and I'm like see this is a
part of the problem and this creates a
massive blowback people getting angry
because that frog for the most part is
used humorously and yeah actually you
use the phrase defensive humor yeah and
it really is and I think I mean this is
I didn't mean to interrupt you Joe but
no please there's there's something
about the idea that the effectiveness of
this meme is that it tangles people with
no sense of humor in knots and that's a
huge part of why those things are
generated that's wisely that's exactly
right yeah yeah yeah I mean I'm fearing
that I'm saying something about this
frog and that there's gonna be something
that's gonna emerge that I should know
about that somehow I'm admitting
something but all I'm saying is what I
see is a lot of people using it to taunt
people yes can't figure out I think
that's the majority of it I do believe
that and I think the same thing about
the cactus Tanny types is that that's
almost all humour yeah and there's some
mass
problem with pushing back against that
and calling those people Nazis and
racists and especially when they're just
using humor and especially when it's
very clear if you look at all the memes
online and I went thoroughly through
Google to find them there are some
abhorrent ones there are some horrible
ones there are some ones that are with
Nazi uniforms there's some there's some
anti Jew ones there's some horrific ones
most of them are not that most of them
the vast majority of them are humorous
and if and again these people are not
coordinating so if one person decides to
make a Mickey Mouse racist meme which by
the way a lot of the early Mickey Mouse
cartoons you could just take a
screenshot and they're [ __ ]
tremendously racist right because
dealing with the sign of the times I
mean images of black people that work
extremely cartoonish you know giant libs
black faces the whole deal or a horribly
racist you could say Mickey Mouse is
[ __ ] racist don't go to Disneyland no
one's saying that right but they could
and this is a slippery slope you start
with the Frog you know and you know
first they came for Pepe and I didn't
say any well if the Frog is racist you
start rendering what isn't racist
cartoon frog but you can make a cartoon
about everything that has ever existed
and make that racist it doesn't mean
that the Frog is racist this is where
it's crazy it's like what percentage of
people are making the Frog racist and
then for the Southern Poverty Law Center
to say that this is a symbol of hate now
this frog well well guess what you just
back these [ __ ] people up against the
wall and you sure their offense is
because now they're realizing oh well
these people are mad they're they're
crate not just mad like angry but mad
like insane like you're not looking at
this thing rationally at all you're
saying that a frog where 99% of the
memes or just humorous or silly now the
Frog is a hate symbol not only a hate
symbol but not see white supremacists I
mean the it you're they're just drying
up all of the space between their
preposterous perspective and the
nightmare at the other end of the
spectrum and the point is almost all of
us live in that intermediate space so
yeah it's almost all thoughts live in
that intermediate space right
there's a variability of all thoughts
you know there's there's flexibility of
all ideas and when you're talking about
something with it words extremely
humorous you're talking about a humorous
frog I mean goddamn need to call that
all hate when sometimes it's hate and
some by who by what are the [ __ ]
people are that did that hateful thing
those are the people that are hateful
not the other ones that are using that
frog for humor I mean this is that the
fact that this is an argument at all
just shows how lost we are in these
ideological arguments is left versus
right extreme end of the spectrum on one
end of the field throwing rocks at the
far end of the field
yeah it's most of us are in the middle
somewhere it's hopeless yeah if we
cannot have discussions about a mirage
Jesus Christ is a nice conclusion yeah
it might be it might be
you